some people may see it as complacent
that you see nothing in the data at the
moment to give you any calls for concern
particularly when you've got people like
the nhs confederation and many senior
scientists arguing that all the warning
signs are there give us a number how bad
do hospital admissions need to get per
day before you do bring in plan b
and can i ask you a question also on on
the antivirals there will be many people
who with me weakened immune systems now
who are very concerned about the surge
hopeful that these drugs might be there
for them will they be
the
first part of your question that we are
concerned i think everyone is right to
be concerned and
and i hope that you i've managed to
just in the last sort of 10 minutes so
express
that that concern that we have and the
reasons why we do with the cases rising
as jenny has just shown in some of the
latest data as well uh deaths i said are
still mostly low but they're still more
than a hundred um and
the the focus though you're very much
remains on what we set out in in plan a
you know those vaccines that they are
working uh they are as you know steve
has just alluded to we've seen from the
data if you look at the hospital
admissions as well
uh the the vaccines are clearly working
we estimate the ons estimates that
they've saved some 130 000 lives they
prevented some 240 000 people from being
hospitalized they've prevented some 24
million infections that's what the
vaccines are doing so if more people get
vaccinated including by the way just to
emphasize again the 5 million or so
across the uk that haven't even had
their first jab and that's why i said if
you know someone please appeal to them
speak to your friends your relatives and
just really sort of nudge them and say
please you know do your bid to help
yourself and help others
and if they've got some weird ideas
about vaccines because they've been
reading misinformation on the internet
and elsewhere then point them in the
right direction but the the vaccines are
absolutely key and as steve has also
said the flu vaccine this year is is
more important than ever it's our
biggest flu vaccination program in
history i think some 35 million uh doses
uh that we've got and then the people
together that we're targeting uh with
that to really help uh you know combat
both those uh viruses
so you that's our plan we remain
cautious and there's no and you ask me
what's the number of um
hospitalizations that we we monitor this
daily we work very quickly obviously the
department with the nhs on a daily basis
and it's not just one particular
number that we're looking at and i'm
very conscious that behind these numbers
you often talk about numbers easily but
there's a person there's an individual
there's a family that's being affected
we're very conscious
of that but as well as hospitalizations
we're looking at the pressure on the nhs
across the board and a e on primary care
on emergency services such as others the
999 the ambulance services so we're
looking at a number of factors and and
taking them all into account on the the
drugs the the new antivirals and we've
the i can tell you a bit more about them
that we've in terms of the total that we
put is 730 000 courses patient courses
we've pub that we've purchased that's
480 000 courses of the merc uh that i
referred to and then 250 000 uh from
pfizer it's important also i think to
say they they have they work differently
they're different mechanisms so
it could be one or the other that might
be deployed in some cases it might be
both they're both oral and they can be
deployed
either if someone has fallen ill
or if um you know from coven or if uh if
if you expect uh that they might do
because there's an outbreak let's say in
a care home you know where you would
naturally have uh vulnerable uh people
it's a really new sort of fresh tool in
our armor these are the first
anti-virals ever that are designed
specifically here for for covid um they
still need to get approval from the mhra
the tests that are publicly available at
the moment have been very encouraging
but we wanted to get there in early and
sign a deal so that we could be one of
the first countries in the world
to receive them should they be approved
by our regulator as safe and effective
steve did you want to add to that yes
well i think as the secretary of state
has said there there is no one number uh
that we would use to think about
triggering further interventions because
it is more complex than that there is a
variety of things that we look at so we
talked about infection rates because
they tell us what's likely to happen in
the nhs in the next few weeks we've
talked about vaccine effectiveness
because that tells us
how many people are likely to require
hospitalization
and
we look at obviously the number of
emissions uh but we also look at what's
happening with flu and other viruses and
what's happening with other emergency
admissions uh so there's a variety of
things that we will be looking at and
continue to look at and of course the
final thing to say is that we do see
geographical variation so what's
happening in one part of the country
might not be happening in another part
of the country that's been typical of
the pandemic over the last 18 months
and it's possible that we will see that
variation again so there is no one
number to look at we have to look at
things in the round uh look at all these
numbers use judgement and of course work
closely with colleagues in uk hsa on the
public health side the department of
health social care to take a collective
judgment uh and on the antivirals it is
indeed great news um i mean as the
secretary of state has said we over the
last 18 months i think one of the things
that has been uh most impressive about
the response of the nhs its ability
to stand up drugs rapidly to investigate
drugs and to work out which drugs are
truly effective at managing this
pandemic and that has undoubtedly saved
many lives in the uk but actually
throughout the world and i think we
should be really proud that a public
health system uh healthcare system
such as ours is very well placed to do
that sort of study and we've shown that
we can we can do it so we have these new
uh anti-virals coming on stream on the
pirivia is likely to be the first one in
terms of who should get it clearly that
is a little bit dependent on the mhra
who need to license it and they will
license it with
their particular licensing conditions
we will of course be taking advice from
clinical experts as to who it is most
appropriate but in general we would want
to target these drugs as we have done in
the past at those at the highest risk
of infection and the highest risk of
hospitalization because that is what we
are most trying to avoid of course death
and so yes i think it is likely that
individuals with weakened immune systems
are likely to be on that list that our
clinical experts would recommend but
let's wait until we get the mhra
licensing and let's wait until we get
the advice of our clinical experts